depuis les hauteurs de l'itie de chance
qu chaque jour les mêmes images
des bombardements incessants sur la
localité voisine de céder aux thoniers
l'armée russe affirme avoir encore gagné
du terrain dans la ville lors d'une rare
apparition
le ministre de la défense a fait le
bilan des dernières avancées
les zones résidentielles de severodonezk
ont été totalement libérée la prise de
contrôle de sa zone industrielle et des
localités voisines se poursuit moscou 10
contrôler 97% de la région de lougansk à
laquelle appartient ce verrou donetsk
dans sa dernière vidéo adressé aux
ukrainiens le président zelensky
maintient que les troubles ukrainienne
tiennent bon malgré tous
nos héros n'abandonnent pas leurs
positions assez verrou de niet dans la
ville les combats de rue font rage
l'armée russe essaie de se déployer dans
le donbass
les après 103 jours de guerre le dombass
ukrainien tient bon
cv road au niet qui est licite chance tu
formes telles d'une agglomération
stratégique si l'armée russe parvenait à
s'en emparer cela lui ouvrirait la route
vers cramatte osc la capitale de la
région de donetsk